-Attorney General
Merrick Garland
has appointed a special counsel
to look into the classified
documents that were found
at President Biden's home
and office
from his time as vice president.
Meanwhile,
Fox News and the GOP
have been stoking a ridiculous
new freakout about gas stoves.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
When it comes
to job approval ratings,
Joe Biden went through a rough
stretch last year.
His numbers were down,
gas prices were up,
inflation was rampant,
and he was constantly
getting hammered
by reporters
with tough questions.
You could see it
in his body language.
During press conferences,
he'd just close his eyes
[ Laughter ]
and put his head down,
like the questions were causing
him physical pain.
That's what my mom does
when my dad starts
telling a story
she's heard multiple times.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my God.
[ Applause ]
Nobody cares
that the car wash forgot
to charge you
for the spray wax."
[ Laughter ]
And you could tell just how
low his confidence was.
Remember how he used
to do that thing
where he'd list
his accomplishments,
but he'd whisper them
into the mic,
like they were a secret?
-Hey, guys.
[ Whispering ]
I think it's time
to give ordinary people
a tax break.
I made it clear to my friends
up in Nantucket and that area
[ Whispering ]
I don't want to hear any more
about you don't like
looking at them.
[ Laughter ]
You know, Michelle, he knows,
we all know --
[ Whispering ]
he couldn't have done it
without you.
[ Laughter ]
Ask me, "Well, you know,
guess what.
Employers can't find workers."
[ Whispering ]
I said, "Yeah.
Pay them more."
[ Laughter ]
I wrote the bill
on the environment.
I got them $1.9 trillion relief,
so far.
[ Laughter ]
Biden was so cautious
at the time,
he was afraid people would
find out what he was doing.
[ As Biden ]
Look, let's just keep this
between you, me,
and the TV cameras, okay?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, was he answering
questions at a press conference
or trying not to spook a horse?
[ Laughter ]
Was that the press conference
where all the reporters
were horses?
[ Laughter ]
Alright, steady, now, steady.
Let's do this
in an orderly fashion.
Any questions?
[ Hooves stampeding ]
Whoa! Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
That whisper is the same move I
pull when I try to trick my kids
into doing something
they don't want to do.
[ As Biden, whispering ]
Alright, guys, I got a super
duper secret mission for you,
but you -- you can't tell Mom.
We got to clean up all our LEGOs
as fast as possible.
[ Laughter ]
And they know it's bull[bleep],
so they immediately start
making demands.
"I want a lollipop!
I want a 'Paw Patrol'!"
And they just keep screaming
at me until I pull a Biden.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Point is things were going great
for Biden, polling-wise,
then he scored a string
of legislative victories,
gas prices fell,
inflation slowed down,
unemployment stayed low,
and Republicans melted down
after a disastrous
midterm election
that left them with a weak
and fractious majority
in the House.
And, according
to The Economist...
I mean, I would say Biden
did cartwheels
through the White House
when he heard those numbers,
but I think we all know
that would not end well
We play --
[ Laughter and applause ]
We play that clip a lot,
but here's the deal --
[ Laughter ]
If you're the most
powerful person in the world
and you somehow trip
up the stairs...
[ Laughter ]
...not once,
but multiple times,
we gonna roast you.
You know, in fact,
I have a button on my desk
that I can press at any time
to roll that clip
in case of an emergency
or if Wally accidentally
has a wardrobe malfunction.
-That's ridiculous, Seth.
How would I have
a wardrobe malfunction?
-Wally, why are you holding
the cue cards
up in front
of your chest like that?
-Oh, this? I just forgot to put
on my nipple covers today.
Want to see?
-No! No! No!
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
The point is Biden's approval
ratings are up now
and Americans are happy
with the way he's doing his job.
He's riding high
and I'm sure nothing --
nothing --
could possibly screw that up.
-Attorney General
Merrick Garland
appointed a special counsel
to oversee the investigation
of classified documents found
on President Biden's property.
-Seth.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
-I don't know.
Just it's a big story.
I thought it'd be a longer clip.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, sure, when Trump --
when it's classified documents
for Trump, 45 seconds!
[ Laughter ]
Let --
Play it one more time.
I'll show you what it was
supposed to look like.
[ Laughter ]
-Attorney General
Merrick Garland
appointed a special counsel
to oversee the investigation
of classified documents found
on President Biden's property.
-Well, [bleep].
[ Laughter and applause ]
Or, as Biden would say --
[ As Biden, whispering ]
Well, [bleep].
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, obviously --
[ Cheering ]
Obviously,
it's not great for Biden
that there's a special counsel
looking into the storage
of classified documents
from his time as vice president,
although, there are
huge differences
between this and Trump's case,
which we'll get to in a sec.
Biden's team reportedly found
a small number of documents
in two locations,
including the garage
where his Corvette is parked,
which he was asked about today.
-According
to President Joe Biden,
these classified documents were
found in his personal library
and in the garage of his home
in Wilmington, Delaware.
Just moments ago,
Biden addressed the matter
very briefly,
saying it was a locked garage
where he also keeps
his Corvette.
-Let me --
I'm going to get a chance
to speak on all of this,
God willing, soon,
but as I said earlier
this week, people --
and, by the way, my Corvette's
in a locked garage, okay?
So, it's not like they're
sitting out in the street.
But, as I said earlier
this week,
people know I take
classified documents
and classified material
seriously.
I also said we're cooperating
fully and completely
with the Justice Department's
review.
-I mean, I guess,
if you're going to store
classified documents somewhere,
you might as well do it next
to your kickass Corvette,
you know,
[ Laughter ]
so that, when they
eventually find them,
you can brag
that you have a Corvette.
[ Laughter ]
If I took classified documents,
I'd keep them next
to my Emmy statue,
just so, when the feds came
to my house, I could say,
"Oh, that whole thing?
It's just an Emmy Award.
It's for songwriting,
but they all count the same!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I will say it's a fitting place
to find them, considering Trump
had his classified documents
at Mar-A-Lago
because Biden's Mar-A-Lago
is definitely
a garage with a Corvette in it.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ] Honey, I'm off
to my private club.
"You mean the garage?"
That's right -- Car-A-Lago!
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
Also, I like Biden's insistence
that the Corvette
was locked away.
[ As Biden ]
That baby's locked away.
It's never coming out.
One time I left it parked
in the street
and some kids
in the neighborhood
took it for a joyride.
I'll never forget what I heard
as they were driving away.
[ Yello's "Oh Yeah" plays ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Bueller!
Now, obviously,
this is not great for Biden
and he shouldn't have had
those documents,
although, personally, I feel
like finding a small number
of classified documents
in someone's home or office
is not a big deal,
as long as they give them back,
which is true for Trump, too.
If Trump had just given back
all the documents
when he was asked,
we wouldn't have had a problem
and that's
the difference, right?
Biden is cooperating fully,
turning over all the documents
immediately, looking for more.
Trump refused to turn them over
for more than a year
after repeated requests,
claims he could declassify them
with his mind,
[ Laughter ]
lied about them,
and even moved them around,
which is what led
to the FBI search
that discovered
even more classified documents
that Trump had refused
to turn over,
which makes the GOP attempt
to draw
a false equivalence
between the two very silly.
-Why aren't they in there
right now, with subpoenas,
going through every single
record there?
-Where's the raid?!
-Classified documents.
Right.
Where is the raid?
And let me -- let me --
-Where's the FBI raid?
-We have a quote here
from Representative James Comer,
from the Oversight Committee,
who said...
-Monday night,
in a post, Trump asked...
[ Laughter ]
-Why would the FBI raid someone
who is already handing over
everything they're asking for?
I don't know, maybe so
they could get a sneak peek
at that Corvette?
[ Laughter ]
"FBI! Open up!
Now, hand over the keys to that
car and retract the roof.
I want to feel the wind
in my hair!"
[ Laughter ]
Why does Trump think they should
raid the White House?
If there's anywhere
a classified document should be,
it's the White House.
[ Laughter ]
Trump would make
an awful detective.
[ As Trump ]
Okay, guys, now we just need
to find some evidence.
I say we raid
the evidence locker.
[ Laughter ]
They're all in bags.
This is very suspicious.
[ Laughter ]
They're all --
There's labels.
Everything's in a bag.
[ Laughter ]
Again, the situation --
there's dead bodies
in the morgue.
Bad news.
[ Laughter ]
Call Homicide.
I opened up one
of those drawers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I figured it out.
[ Laughter ]
Again, the situations
are very different,
although,
the timing is not great,
given that Biden has been
riding high in the polls.
And, as a general rule,
whenever Biden is riding high,
the GOP and Fox News
crank up the freakometer
to try to scare you
about something dumb,
like the War on Christmas
or woke M&M's.
For example,
you might remember that,
early in Biden's presidency,
Fox claimed he was trying
to ban hamburgers.
-Say goodbye to your burgers,
if you want to sign up
for the Biden climate agenda.
-He wants to cut out 90% of the
red meat that you all eat.
That's four pounds a year.
-No burgers on July 4th.
No steaks on the barbie.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure middle America
is just going to love that.
I'm sorry,
but what American refers
to the barbecue as the barbie?
[ Laughter and applause ]
You sound like
an Australian spy trying
to blend in
as an undercover American.
[ Cheering ]
"Hey, blokes, who wants to grill
some American hamburgers
on the barbie?
[ Laughter ]
Then we can go on a walkabout
into the Outback
to look for some koalas,
maybe play the didgeridoo.
I mean the guitar!
[ Australian accent ]
Crikey!
I think they're on to me, mate!
[ Laughter and applause ]
You got to get me out.
They're as cross
as a frog in a sock, oi!
[ Laughter ]
I think that was a German
pretending to be --
[ Laughter ]
That was a German spy
pretending to be
an Australian spy,
pretending to be an American.
[ Laughter ]
That's the depths of the accent
work I'm doing.
[ Laughter ]
Hard as it is to believe,
none of that was true.
Despite greedy
old Joe Biden trying
to get his sweaty paws
on your hamburgers,
red meat was still legal
on July 4th,
so, now, Fox has moved on to yet
another loopy little freakout --
Biden is coming to your house
to take away your gas stove.
-Could the Biden administration
be coming for your gas stove?
The answer is yes!
-Joe Biden's climate
change agenda
now targeting your kitchen.
-Your family dinner is
about to get a lot less tasty.
-The White House
is now attempting to ban
all gas ovens and burners.
-Biden's coming
for your gas stove.
-A ban on your gas stove.
-Ban gas-powered stoves.
-A stove like this one
could be banned soon.
-Your gas stove may be buh-bye.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not giving up my gas stove.
-If you touch my propane,
then I'm really going
to be ticked off, right?
-Yeah, it's not happening.
-Nobody's going to tell me
I can't cook with gas!
-[ As Pirro ]
Nobody's going to tell me
I can cook with gas!
[ Laughter ]
You could try,
but I'm not going to hear you
because I never stop talking
and, when I talk,
I can't even hear a jet plane
when it flies overhead!
[ Laughter ]
Now, I do say, I just realized
if you averaged out Joe Biden
and Jeanine Pirro,
you would get one normal
speaking voice.
[ Laughter ]
Then there was
Congressman Ronny Jackson
from Texas.
You might remember him.
Jackson had his own little
meltdown on Twitter,
where he wrote...
[ Laughter ]
I do like to imagine
what circumstances would lead
to someone dying
while clutching their gas stove.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Honey, I think there's
a burglar downstairs.
Hand me my stove."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then the cops would show up
all confused.
"Well, I guess we better pry
that thing
from his cold, dead hands."
[ New York accent ]
Good news, Chief --
the hands aren't actually
that cold,
you know, on account of him
holding the stove.
[ Laughter ]
Although, I think
my favorite example has
to be this one,
from Tucker Carlson,
who was in the middle
of a segment about something
completely different
when he said this --
-At the same time, these same
people are telling us
that it's "dangerous"
to use a natural gas stove
in your home,
because of emissions,
but they're not concerned
about smoking meth?
[ Laughter ]
Like at some point,
you have to wonder like
what's really going on here?
-Yeah, man, what the hell?!
When are they finally going
to make meth illegal?
[ Laughter ]
But he's right about one thing.
You really do have to wonder.
[ As Carlson ]
I mean, what's going on here?
They want to take
your stove away,
but they don't care
if you smoke meth?
Are they going
to take your stove
and replace it with a meth lab?
[ Laughter ]
And then if everyone has
a meth lab in their home,
what will happen
to the price of meth
on the street?
[ Laughter ]
Will this put
hardworking Americans,
like Gustavo Fring, out of work?
[ Laughter ]
Maybe you're thinking,
"Can't he just fall back
on his restaurant,
Los Pollos Hermanos?"
Not anymore, he can't.
[ Laughter ]
Because they took his stove.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, here's what --
...here's what's actually
going on.
Recent studies have confirmed
something scientists have been
researching for a long time,
which is that gas stove
pollution can be harmful
and cause a variety
of health problems,
including childhood asthma.
In fact, the risks are...
Now, let me just stop here
to say
that it doesn't exactly shock me
to find out
that burning gas inside your
house on a daily basis
might not be like
the best thing for you.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe this is new information,
but it can't be that surprising.
Like on the spectrum
of shocking revelations,
there's finding out that gas
stoves are bad for you
[ Raising voice ]
and then there's finding out
that Prince Harry
had frostbite on his penis
at William and Kate's wedding.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That is a real thing
from his book.
I did not make that up.
[ Laughter ]
Wally, have you ever had
frostbite on your penis?
-Seth, it's funny
you should ask.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, anyway...
[ Laughter ]
Then a member of the
U.S. Consumer Product
Safety Commission said...
That was quickly
clarified yesterday
by the chair of the commission,
who said...
"...and the commission has
no proceedings to do so."
So, the whole freakout was
much ado about nothing.
No one is taking your gas stove.
That said, you can get cash
incentives from the government
to switch to an electric
or induction stove --
if you want --
which is better for both you
and the environment,
but it is up to you.
If you feel really strongly
about it,
you can keep cooking with gas.
You can even use gas to cook,
as Americans would say...
-Steaks on the barbie.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]